welcome back now the next conservative
candidate for mayor of London isn't your
stereotypical Tory he's a former youth
worker who's worked with communities
blighted by issues including knife crime
Sean Bailey wants the top job at City
Hall and he joins us now thank you for
being with us well we sell a bit there
in the introduction but you're not you
know that the person that people always
think of when they think of what's
stereotypical conservative is you know
you bought up by a single mom on a
council estate why did you become a
conservative I think for me because life
is about forward progress
I almost help people move forward I like
the idea of being independent and being
responsible and they for me a quart or
eval use I don't hold too much so I'm
not a typical Tory on one sense maybe
not but those values of decency hard
work the universal worldwide sight for
me actually in my heart I am a very
typical Tory okay fair enough
and now you've said that one of your
priorities if you become mayor is to try
and tackle crime so do you think that
London is more or less safe than when
you grew up it's definitely less safe
that is beyond doubt when I took I've
been in youth work of 25 plus years when
we were younger we used to travel across
200 got in a 7 bus go to off the street
I remember I discovered London by riding
along the Grand Union Canal there's no
way the kids I work with now would do
that and why not because every crossing
separate different people's territories
and rightness now that literally be
life-threatening you'd be looking at
potentially being attacked murdered and
we focus so hard on life crime but if
burglaries on the rise all those kind of
things there's absolutely no doubt in my
mind that London is more dangerous now
and it's been for years and why is that
there's a number of factors I think some
of the main reasons is we haven't pushed
down enough from crime so in a London
that I will be building will you be
having criminals under pressure not
communities we don't intervene early
enough with crime we're not supporting
young people enough to learn how to
avoid those things when I grew up
resilience was easier to come by our
communities were more resilient and as I
became a youth worker my main thing was
to teach people
here's Gerardo pitfalls head of things
that will drag you into crime here the
outcomes that you don't want it make me
have to have many tough conversations
some of which weren't particularly
polite certain oh they but there were
tough conversations for communities and
tough play
but it meant that will keep our young
children say that it's hard in it I mean
coming down hard and crying what do you
mean by that is this I'm stopping search
is it longer jail sentences what is it
it's all of the above so the first thing
is you need to get more bobbies on the
beat because there's a perception that
the roads are dangerous that like what
wasn't be time it was a concept it's
wasn't it who cut the numbers a
policeman on the beat I mean three
thousand fewer police officers in London
compared to 2010 but that's but that's
about police activity that's about
choices isn't it so if you look at City
Hall now we're about to have a 37
percent rise in staff we should have
spent much if not all of that money on
police
I've written a plan to give us a
thousand extra bobbies on a beat and
eight hundred detectives with the money
we currently have and the reason I've
done that is this two things it's not
just what's it all there is it's you
know about in the national government
but you know but in the concert of
government since 2010 London is about
City Hall isn't it because we have the
power to make a change I'm not in
politics to to have arguments about the
past it's about what we do going forward
we have the money right here right now
for more than two years myself and other
people have been saying to the mayor you
can produce more officers for the place
that you are responsible for and we've
dragged our heels and here we are and
why I talk about Bobby's on a beat the
first thing we have to support frontline
policing and also police staff the
people do the back-office stuff because
it allows more police to be out on the
street and also we need more detectives
because a problem in London in
particular is criminals are now
believing they're getting away with
crime so they keep doing it they were
told by the mayor take 10 years to solve
violence so our children are arming
ourselves because they've been told they
won't it will be 10 years before any
change if you have an attempted to carry
knife I'm lucky I haven't been I grew up
in an area and a time because I'm used
to be here youth I grew up at a time
where it just didn't feel that dangerous
I didn't need to do that and I grew up
in a tight-knit community where we knew
who the bad boys were we could avoid
them ok now I want to address some
things that you've said in the past and
because they have come out in the media
you've had a lot of criticism for some
of the comments that you may lead around
a decade ago now that was a while ago
but you were you know let's be honest
you're in your 30s you weren't a young
boy ok and so I just want to have a look
at one thing first this is what you said
in 2005 about women who are good-looking
all girls were good-looking
if a girl appeals to one
way she'll appeal to all of them she'll
tend to have been around I mean for me
that's quite depressing it's kind of
that age-old thing about you know women
basically blamed having sex so two
things I never actually said that that
was me having a conversation with
someone but let's be clear I'm talking
about a very poor community facing very
you're talking about you say you said
that when you talk to teenagers about
sex you warn them that it's not all
about if they're looking clean then
she'll be less like to have an affection
if a girl appeals to one that way she'll
appeal to all of them she'll tend to
that's around myth-busting because we're
talking about boys who live in a very
sexualized environment it's traded as a
as a way of being popular or not and
like I said you're talking about the
poorest communities you know dealing
with the toughest issues and it's is
people like me who on the front line
having those conversations what makes me
laugh about your slick career
politicians who run around saying nice
things about communities they always
talk about youth work what do they think
youth workers are doing what kind of
conversations do they think we're having
that other people won't have with young
people that's what's being talked about
it's the language there isn't it that
one in course it was it was it the
smoothest language of course not of
course not and if if anybody's satin if
ik about why did he say that you
remember you're talking about 10-15
years ago when I was faced with young
people have been stabbed and murdered in
all kinds of things so the language
isn't the smoothest but I'm not I'm not
I'm not sitting home thinking what will
look good on sky I'm thinking how can I
get across these people and of course
the young people I'm speaking to I'm
having to mirror their language that
they're using another thing that you
said and about single mothers as well
I'm quite interested to talk about this
because of course you were brought by
single mother you said many of the first
single mums were housed in my part of
London reassuring them that it was
acceptable even desirable for mothers to
have babies on their own so is it
acceptable to think - oh sorry
there's another one I forgot that and
you went on to say that that assumption
is flawed because we now know that a
child growing up without a father is so
much more likely to be disadvantaged so
let's take these two things so the first
things about vulnerability we had a
system and in many ways we still do now
that encourages poor communities to make
themselves vulnerable in order to
receive benefits or to be supported
that's why for instance you've local
city or one of the biggest mistakes
we've done the mayor's removed the
target for family housing so Ken had one
bite at one I'm Sadiq Khan has removed
it those are the kind of things that put
people in
in in those in those situations there
you have to make a decision do I make
myself vulnerable or not and for me
that's terrible that's why I got
involved in politics and hoping about
grown up in a single family I grew up in
a single-parent family I work with many
people in single-parent families and the
statistics will show that you are much
more likely to be exposed to poverty and
you no matter which side of political
divide you are and you will know that
poverty is a tough tough nut to crack so
again when you have in conversations the
people who are having to make these
decisions on a daily basis you have to
have a realistic conversation okay thank
you very much we're out of time sadly
thank you